everyone I'm dorsa and this week I'll be
teaching the state-based models and the
pine is for the next couple of weeks for
me to teach the state base models MVPs
and games and and after that Percy will
come back and talk about the later so
the later topics so a few announcements
so homework three is out there just make
sure to look at that and then the grades
for homework one will be coming out soon
so just yeah all right so so let's talk
about state based models let's talk
about search so just to start I was
thinking maybe we can start with this
question if you can so basically you're
gonna let me tell you what the question
is and then think about it and then
after I don't get this working so so the
question is you have a farmer and the
farmer has a cabbage a goat and a wolf
and it's on one side of the river
everything is on one side of the river
so you have this river you have a farmer
we have the farmer with the cabbage the
goat and the wolf yeah and the farmer
wants to go to the other side of the
river and take everything with himself
and but the thing is the farmer has a
boat and in that boat can only fit two
things so the farmer can be in it with
with one of these other things okay so
the question is how many crossings can
candy farmer do to take everything on
the other side of the river and are a
bunch of constraints the constraint is
if you leave the cabbage and go together
the goat is going to eat the cabbage so
you can't really do that if you leave
wolf with the goat
the wolf is going to eat the goat you
can't really do that how many crossings
should you take to take everything to
the other side think about it talk to
your neighbors
I'll get this working everyone clear on
the question
[Music]
the link doesn't work because I can't
connect to internet but alright so okay
so how many people think it is four four
crossings five six six
some people think six seven no solution
no solution okay so the point is
actually not like what the answer is yes
it would come back to this question and
try to solve it but I think the
important point to think about right now
is how you went about solving it so so
what were you thinking and what was the
process that you were thinking when you
were trying to solve solve this problem
and that is kind of the commonality that
search problems have and and we want to
think about those types of problems or
it's it's more challenging to answer
these types of questions and let's say
reflex based type of questions so so
that's kind of just a motivating
examples that you will come back later
and here's an xkcd on this so basically
one potential solution is the farmer
takes the goat goes to the other side
comes back takes the cabbage goes to the
other side and just leaves the wolf
because why would he need a wolf why
would a former need a wolf so if yeah I
searched for you probably were thinking
about this and I get surprised like an
interesting point in it because
sometimes maybe you should change the
problem your model is completely wrong
maybe maybe sometimes you should rethink
and go back to your model I try to fix
that but anyways so we'll come back to
this question so all right so this was
our guideline for the class and we have
already talked about reflex based model
so we have talked about machine learning
and how that can get applied and now we
want to start talking about state based
models this week we're going to talk
about search problems next week
MVP's and then the week after we're
going to talk about games and if you
remember the kind of the guideline that
we had for the class was we were
thinking about these three different
paradigms of modeling right we talked
about this already so modeling inference
and learning so for reflux based models
we talked about this already right so
well with the model B Roley can be a
linear predictor or it can be a neural
network so that was the model and then
we talked about and friends but in the
case of reflex based models it was
really simple it was just function
evaluation you have you had your neural
network and you just go about evaluating
it and that was inference and we also
spent some time talking about learning
so how would we use like what's a
gradient descent to try to fit the
parameters of the model okay so similar
thing with search based models you want
to talk about these three different
paradigms that we have in the class and
then the plan is to talk about models
and in France today and then under
Wednesday we'll talk about learning and
we kind of have the same sort of format
next week too so we're going to start
talking about modeling and inference on
Mondays Wednesdays are gonna be about
learning so so just to give you an idea
what the plan is
all right so so what are search problems
let's start with a few motivating
examples so so one potential example one
can think of is is route-finding so you
might have a map and you want to go from
point A to point B on the map and you
have an objective so you want to maybe
find a shortest path or the fastest path
or most scenic time and and that is your
objective and the things you can do is
you can take a bunch of action so you
can do things like go straight turn left
turn right and then the answer for the
search problem is going to be a sequence
of actions if you want to go from A to B
with the shortest path the answer that
one would give is maybe turned right
first and then turn left and then right
again
or any or any of these sequences okay so
so this is just a canonical example of
what a search problem is there are a few
other examples so for example you can
think of robot a robot motion planning
so if you have a robot that wants to go
from point A to point B then it might
want to have different objectives for
doing that so again the question might
be what is the fastest way of doing it
or what is the most energy efficient way
of getting the robot to do that or or
what is the safest way of doing it like
another question that we are interested
in is what is the most expressive or
legible way of robot doing it so so
people can understand what a robot
really wants so you might have again
various types of objectives you can
formalize that and then the actions that
you can take in the case of the robot
motion planning is the robot is going to
have different joints and each one of
the joints can translate and can rotate
so translation and rotation are the type
of actions that you can take so so in
this case I have a robot with seven
seven joints and then I need to tell
what each one of those joints should do
in terms of translation and rotation
this is my robot yes it's a fetch robot
alright so so let's look at another
example so games this is a fun example
so you might think about something like
Rubik's Cube or or this 15 puzzle and
and again what do you want to do as a
search problem well you want to you want
to end up in configuration that's
desirable right so you want to end up in
a configuration where you have this type
of configuration of rubik's cube or the
15 puzzle so that is the goal that's the
objective and then the action as you can
move pieces around here so the sequence
of actions might be how you're moving
these pieces are on to get that
particular configuration of the 15
puzzle ok so again another example of
what a search problem is machine
translation is an interesting one it's
not necessarily the most natural thing
you might think about when you think
about search problems but what it is
actually you can think about it as a
search problem again so imagine you have
a phrase in different language and you
want to translate it to English so what
is the objective here well you can think
of the objective as going to fluent
English and preserving meaning so that
is the objective that one would have in
machine translation and then the type of
actions that you're taking is you're
appending words so you start with there
and then your appending blue to it and
you're appending hostage so so as you're
appending these these different
different words those are the actions
that you're taking so so in some sense
you can have any complex sequential task
and the sequence of actions that you
would get to get to your objective is
this going to be the answer for your
search problem and you can pose it as a
search problem ok all right so so what
is different between let's say reflex
based models and search problem so if
you remember reflex based models the
idea was you'd have an input X and then
we wanted to find this F for example a
classifier that that would output
something like like this Y which is labo
it's a plus 1 or minus 1 so the common
thing in in these reflex based models
was we were outputting this this one
they
this one in this case action being minus
1 or plus 1 again in search problems the
idea is I've given an input I'm given a
state and then given that I have that
state what I want to output is a
sequence of actions so I do want to
think about what happens if I take this
action like how is that going to affect
the future of my actions okay so so the
key idea in search problems is you need
to consider future consequences of the
actions you take at the currency like
just outputting one thing and so if you
rerun it so the question is yeah is it
not the same as like I'm rerunning it I
asked you to thing and then I rerun it
again
and then you could do that but that ends
up being a little bit of a that would be
something similar to a greedy algorithm
or like let's say I want to get to the
door and I want to find a find the
fastest way and and right now if I just
look at like my current state maybe I
think the fastest way of getting there
is going this way but if I actually
think about a horizon and I think about
how this action is going to affect my
future I might call with different
sequence of actions yeah all right okay
so and then we've already seen this
paradigm so let's start talking about
modeling and in France during this class
so this is the the plan for today so
we're going to talk about three
different algorithms for for doing
inference for search problems so so
we're going to talk about research which
is the most naive thing one could do to
solve some of these search problems but
that's the simplest thing we can start
with and then after that you want to
look at improvements of that doing
dynamic programming or uniform cost
search based problem another flex pays
problem the very fact that in a respect
face problem the output that you give
does not influence an exchange and it
doesn't search yeah that's true yeah so
so the output that you get and search
problem instance action it actually
influences your future yeah that's a
good way of actually thinking about it
all right so so let's talk about
research so let's go back to our
favorite example okay so we have the
farm area cabbage go-to in both so let's
think about all possible actions that
one can take when we have this farmer
cabbage goat interval okay so so a bunch
of things we can do is the farmer
I can go to the other side of the river
with the boat alone so this triangle
here just means like going to the other
side of that de river the farmer can
take the cabbage so C's for cabbage G's
for it go to WC for both so another
possible action is the farmer takes a
cabbage or the farmer takes a goat or
the farmer takes a wolf and goes to the
other side of the river you also have a
bunch of other actions the farmer can
come back the farmer I can come back
with the cabbage come back with the goat
collaborative so I'm basically numerate
enumerate all possible actions that that
one could ever do and sure none of some
of these might not be possible in
particular States but I'm just creating
this library of actions things that are
possible yeah so then when we think
about this as a search problem we could
create a search tree which which
basically starts from an initial state
of where things are and then we can kind
of think about where we could go from
that initial state so the search tree is
more of a what if what if tree which
which allows you to think about what are
the possible options that you can take
so conceptually what it looks like is
you're starting with your initial state
where everything is on one side of the
river so those two lines are it is the
river white and you can take a bunch of
actions right like one possible action
is you can take the cabbage and go to
the other side of the river and you end
up in that state and that's a little not
a good state so I'm making that red well
why is that because the wolf is going to
eat the goat that's not that great okay
and every action every crossing let's
say let's say every crossing takes cost
of one so that one that you see on the
edge is the cost of that action okay so
that didn't really work that well what
else can I do well I can I can do
another action I can I can from the
initial State
I can take the goat and go to the other
side of the river that ends up in this
configuration from there the farmer
could come back take the cabbage go to
the other side end up in this
configuration the farmer can come back
that's again not a great States because
cabbage and goat are left on the other
side of the river good is going to eat
the cabbage that's not great what else
can I do well the farmer can come back
with the goat and
once the farmer comes back with the goat
the farmer leaves the goat takes the
wolf goes to the other side comes back
gets the goat again and then okay so so
how many steps is to stay cool one two
three four five six and seven so so the
ones mice are seven that was a right
answer and that is kind of the idea of
getting to this so you could have this
giant tree where you go to different
states but we can actually have like a
counter that tells you if I visited that
state and if you have visited that state
maybe you don't want to go there again
because because you have already
explored all the possible actions from
there you're not done with this tree
though right like I found this this good
state here but maybe there's a better
way of like getting there I don't know
yet I haven't explored everything so so
what I can do is I can actually explore
all these other things that that one
could do not gonna go over them but
there is another solution and turns out
that other solution also takes seven
steps so it's not necessarily a better
solution but but you got to explore all
of that because there could be another
solution later on that that is better
than the seven steps all right the wiser
okay all right so so this is how the
search tree looks like oh that's a very
good point thank you for saying so for
CPD students I'll try to repeat the
questions I always forget this I'll try
to repeat the questions the question was
was the slice or the slides are up they
are up they should be up okay all right
so going back to our search problem so
we can try to formalize this search
problem so let's actually think about it
more formally so what are the things
that we need to keep track of so so we
have a start state so let's define s
start to be the start state in addition
to that we can we can define this
function called actions which returns
all possible actions from States so
actions is a function of state if I'm in
a state it basically tells me what are
the actions I can take from
I can can you find this cost function so
this cost function takes a state in
action and tells me what is the cost of
that and in this example the cost of
crossing the river was just one but you
can imagine having different cost values
we can have a successor function that
basically takes a state in action and
and tells us where we end up at so if
I'm state s and I take action a where
would I end up at and that's the
successor function and then we were
going to define and is end the function
which basically checks if you're in an
end state where we don't have any other
possible actions we can you can think of
it as a way of like finite state machine
type of type of way of looking at it
yeah so like we use a similar type of
formalism for MVPs and games too so it's
just good idea to get like all these
hormones outside but start state
transitions cost position and action an
extravert this thing so then so so the
action okay so so action depends on the
state so you start from start state
where you haven't taken any actions
right and then from that start state
then you can think about all possible
like right up there so you're in that
start state and then you can think about
all possible actions you can take
and then those actions depend on current
state but they don't depend on the
future State right so based on my
current state everything is on one side
of the river I can think about all
possible actions I can take and where I
know where I end up at and then after
that's like the next action depends on
that that state so it's a sequential
thing okay yes you have all the
information on the actions and the cost
that you could do beforehand how is this
conceptually different than like a mini
cost flow convex optimization
okay so how is it different from a kind
of convex optimization type of row so we
have you have an objective here and you
can think of what that objective is and
based on what that objective is you can
have different methods for solving it
right so so you can basically formulate
this as an optimization problem where
you saw you look for the
solution to a search problem as an
optimization problem that's perfectly a
perfect way of doing it and then we are
going to talk about various types of
methods for solving this problem today
yeah all right so so let's look at
another example so this is a
transportation problem this so okay so
basically what we want to do is we have
straight blocks from 1 through n so 1 2
3 so on so these are straight thoughts
and what we want to do is we basically
want to travel from from 1 2 to some n
number and we have two possible actions
so at any state let's say on state s at
any state I can either walk and if I
walk I end up in s plus 1 so if I'm in 3
I'm going to end up in 4 and walking
takes 1 minute or I can take this magic
and if magic tram takes any state
s 2 2 times s so if I mean 3 then I'm
going to end up in 6 by taking the magic
trap and the magic time
always takes 2 minutes doesn't matter
from that so so if I'm in to all end up
in 4 or 5 min 5 I can end up in 10 by
taking the trap ok so so I have two
possible actions in any of these states
and what I want to do is I want to go
from 1 to N and then I want to basically
do that in the shortest time possible so
we did with the least amount of costs
there's a problem all right so so this
is kind of like what the search problem
is so what we want to do is first off
you want to just formalize it and I'm
gonna do that here I'm not gonna do wife
solutions cuz I'm not Percy and I did
that once and it was a disaster so we
are going to yeah I've taped these in
2018 but basically you're going to go
over it together so so let's just do
that so we're going to define the search
problem this problem so we're
going to define a class for
transportation problems you're going to
separate our search
from our algorithms because remember
modeling is separate from inference so
let's just have a constructor for this
transportation problem it takes n
because we are at n box okay so n is the
number of blocks
well
all right so so then you have miss to
have a start state we are starting from
one so block one and then we need to
define is end state so as n state
basically checks if you have reached an
or not because we have to get to there
and in okay alright so what else do
we need
so we have a successor function you also
have a cost function I'm gonna put both
of them together cuz that is just easier
so the successor in cost function I'm
saying let's just give it state s and
then given a state it's going to return
this triple of action new state costs so
I give it a state as the initial state
and then it just returns all possible
actions with the new states I can end up
at and how much does that cost yeah so
what are my options
well if I'm in state s I can walk to s
plus 1 that cost 1 if I'm in state s I
can take the tram I can end up in to s
and that costs to okay so that's how I'm
creating my Triple C and I need to check
if I don't pass the enth walk remember
like you have n box so we don't want to
pass then walk ok so so that's just to
make sure that we don't pass it so we
are still below tenth block and then
this is what my successor in cost
function will return the debt triples
okay so let's just return that okay so
that is my transportation problem let's
make sure it does the think the way we
want it so let's say we have 10 blocks
and now I want to print my
transportation of my successor and cost
much analysis let's say I'm returning
successor and cost for 3 what should I
get
so from 3 I can have two actions right I
can either walk or I can take the tram
if I walk it costs one if I take the
tram it costs two I'll end up in 4 or 6
let's just try I don't know 9
if I'm a state 9 I can only do one thing
I can walk right cuz remember the the
block is number of blocks is 10 and I
can't go beyond that so alright okay so
that was yeah let's go back here so that
was just defining the search problem
yeah and I haven't told you guys like
how to solve it right this is we were
just doing the modeling right now so we
just modeled this problem just coated it
up modeling it means what is this what
are the actions what is a successor
function what is the cost function
defining an is end function say but what
the initial state is okay so so now I
think we are ready to think about the
algorithm in terms of like going in
solving these types of search problems
so the simplest algorithm we want to
talk about is backtracking search so the
idea of backtracking search is maybe I
can draw a tree here is you're starting
from an initial state and then you have
a bunch of possible actions and then you
end up in some state and you have a
bunch of water possible actions let's
say you have two actions possible and
this can become this exponentially blows
up so I'm going to stop soon all right
so so create this tree and this tree has
some branching factor it's number of
actions you have at every at every state
and then it also has some depth so that
is how many levels you go down to let me
just define that by D okay
and now their solutions down in this no
it's right so so we want to figure out
what those solutions are and
backtracking search just does the
simplest thing possible what it does is
it starts from this initial state and
it's going to go all the way down here
and if it doesn't find a solution it's
gonna go back here and then try again
and try again and it's gonna go over all
over the tree because there might be a
better solution down here too so it
needs to actually go over all of the
truth okay so I'm going to have a table
of algorithms cuz you're going to talk
about a few of them yeah algorithms
what sort of costs they allow
in terms of time how bad they are in
terms of space so if you've taken an
algorithms course like some of these are
probably familiar so alright so we
talked about Mack tracking search
tracking search that is basically this
algorithm that goes through pretty much
everything and it allows any type of
costs so I can have any costs right I
can have pretty much any cost I want on
these edges because I'm going over all
of the tree it doesn't matter what these
costs okay so how bad is this in terms
of in terms of time so in terms of time
I'm going over the full tree like going
over the full tree then then this is
going to have this exponential blow-up
where I'm looking at order of B to the D
where B is again my branching factor and
D is the depth of the tree because in
terms of time this is not a good
algorithm maybe in terms of time I have
to go over everything in the tree and
that's the size of my tree and in terms
of space in terms of space what I mean
is I need to figure out what was what
was the sequence of actions I needed to
take to get to some solution so let's
say that my solution is down here my
solution is down here then for mean or
like I hate to store a bunch of things
to know how I got here and the things I
need to store the parents of this node
and that is depth of them so in terms of
space this algorithm takes order of D
because because that is like the things
that I need to store in my memory to be
able to recover everything between the
space be bigger your B to the D as well
because until you get that you need to
have the space to have everything right
no so actually we will talk about
breadth-first search later which does
require have a larger space so so the
reason you can forget it is the only
history that I need to keep track of is
this particular branch right I don't
need to figure out like I don't need to
keep track of like actually the history
of all these other notes I can throw
those out but or something else like
breadth-first search where we will talk
about in a few slides you actually need
to keep track of like the history of
everything else
so so let me get back to that in a few
slides but for this one make the clean
ideas yeah like I want to know how I got
there to know how I got there I just
need to know like the minimum cost to
reach your point or is it to find
whether like so it depends on what your
objective is like it really depends on
what the search problem is asking so so
in the case of that farmer good example
the search problem is asking you want to
move everything to the other side of the
river so you have that criteria and you
want to find the minimum cost one so you
also add other criteria so it really
depends on what the search problems
asking and some of these notes might be
solutions some of them might not be
solutions so it's a really difference
all right so so let's just look at these
on the slide so the memory is order of T
it's actually small it's nice in terms
of time this is not a great algorithm
right because even if you're branching
factors too if the depth of the tree is
50 then this is going to blow up like
immediately so a lot of these tree
search algorithm said you're going to
talk about like they have the same
problem so so they pretty much have the
same time complexity if you're going to
just look at very minimal improvements
of them and then after that we'll talk
about dynamic programming and uniform
cost search which are polynomial
algorithms that are much better than
okay all right so let's actually let's
go back to a tram example and let's try
to write up what backtracking search
does so alright so we defined our model
our model is the search problem this
particular transportation search problem
it could be anything else and now we're
going to kind of have this main section
with where we were going to put in like
our algorithms in it and you're going to
write them as general as possible so so
we can apply them to other types of
search problems yeah so let's define
backtracking search it takes a search
problem it can take the transportation
problem okay all right so and then we're
going to basically in backtracking
search what we were doing is we were
recursing on every state given that we
have a history of getting there and the
total cost that it took us to get there
okay so so at the state having gone some
history and some accumulated cost so
far we are going to basically recurse on
that state and look at the children of
that state okay so so we're going to
explore the rest of the subtree from
from that particular state
all right so how do we do that
well we got to make sure that you're not
in an end state or if you're an in-state
like we can actually update the best
solution so far okay so let's put that
for to do so so the bunch of things we
need to do we need to figure out if we
are in an end state if you are well we
gotta we gotta update our best solution
if you're not in an end state then we
are going to recurse on children
all right so you can do that later and
then in general this recurse function is
going to we're going to call it on on
the on the start State so let's actually
do that too so so what backtracking
search does is it calls this recursive
function on the initial State dead
behalf with history of none right if you
don't have any history yet and and cost
this zero so far because we haven't
really gone anywhere so so we start with
a start state we call recurse on it okay
and how do we recurse on children well
we have defined this this successor and
cost function so by calling that
successor and cost function on state
then we can get action new state and
costs so so we get this triple of action
news dating cost
and then we can basically recurse on the
new state I'm not putting the histories
right now in this code so so you need to
keep track of the history too but let's
just not worry about the history oh I
guess I'm putting it in this one I mean
the later ones I will not put them but
but basically the history is keeping
track of like how you got there and
total cost is going to be what you've
got so far costs the cost of this is new
state action yeah okay so we need to
keep track of the best solution so far
so I'm just going to find a dictionary
here just to make sure that we keep
track of it and we'll Python scoping
okay
and then the place we are going to
update our best solution so far is that
to do that is left right so if you're in
an end state then we can actually update
the best solution so far yeah and what
do we want in our best solution well we
want to know what the cost is so so you
can start with cost of infinity and
anything below infinity is better and
then we're going to start with a history
of empty but we're going to throw up
that's history too so that's the
initialization of best solution so far
then we are going to update that right
if you're in an end state if the total
cost that we have right now is smaller
than the best solution so far then
you're going to update that best
solution and then you're going to update
its history with whatever its histories
all right and that's it that's
backtracking search okay so let's just
make sure it does the thing so to do
that we are going to actually know we
got to return the best solution so far
all right so now we have defined this
transportation problem now what I want
to do is I want to call backtracking
search on the transportation problem
yeah so that all sounds good I need to
write a print function also so to be
able to print things so I'm going to
just write a generic print function that
we can call on any of these types of
problems so let's let's define a print
solution function that just like prints
things the way you want them so we get
the solution and we're going to just
unpack the cost and history and just
print the constant history nicely
you
all right so I can i can use this print
solution for pretty much all the other
algorithms we'll talk about today too
and you're going to talk about how we
get there with the history so now I have
my print function I have my backtracking
search algorithm I've defined my
transportation problem I can just call
it on this transportation problem it's
been ten blocks so as you guys can see
here so the total cost is six so what
this means is for going from city 1 to
city to city 10 then this is the best
solution I got a walk walk walk walk and
then after that take the tram guys like
I end up in five and then after that
it's actually worth taking the tram and
paying constant let's try it out for 20
what do you think is the answer for 20
so similar here for a walk walk walk
until we get to five then we take the
tram then we take the tram again across
the state and then if it is 100 it's a
little bit more interesting if you have
100 so you're walking and then you're
taking the tram and you get to 24 and
you want you have that one step to get
to 25 which is a good stay because then
you can just multiply that by 2 so so
you walk for that one step and take the
tram again so what if I want to try out
a much larger number of blocks so is
this gonna work no cuz cuz remember that
time was order of B to the D that wasn't
that great so let's try that
Oh because maximum recursion to him we
can fix that so let's try fix impact so
if you can't you can set your recursion
limit to be whatever so if we try that
is this gonna work
[Laughter]
well now it's just gonna take a long
time right it's not gonna give you an
answer because it's gonna just take a
long time so all right
okay let's go back here alright so that
was backtracking search right so all we
was doing was just going over all of
this tree and it was taking exponential
time as you saw and we just tried it out
on that transportation problem that
really fine so we just defined a search
problem we use this really simple search
algorithm to find solutions for that and
then that's what we have so far so so
now what we want to do is we want to we
want to come up with a few better
improvements of this backtracking search
again don't get your hopes up it's not
that big of an improvement but but we
can do some something better so so the
first improvement you want to make is by
using this algorithm called depth-first
search so you might have heard of it the
FS or depth-first search okay so the
restriction that DFS puts in is that
your cost has to be zero so your cost
has to be you actually draw a line
between them so okay so so we're talking
about the investor and the restriction
is the cost has to be zero so so what
the offense does is it basically does
exactly the same thing as backtracking
search but once it finds a solution down
here then it is done it basically
doesn't like explore the rest of this
thing and the reason it can do that if
the cost of all these edges is zero so
if the cost of all these edges are zero
then if I find a solution I found a
solution I don't need to like find its
better solution that's because that that
is good enough like anything like fine
also has a cost of zero so my dad's all
just returned to so an example of that
is if you have Rubik in rubik's cube
like if you find a solution then you
have found a solution right there are
million different ways of like getting
to a solution but like you just want one
and then if you find one then you're
happy you are done okay so as you can
see this is a very very slight
improvement to backtracking search what
happens is in terms of in terms of space
it's still the same thing so it's order
of D so in terms of space nothing has
changed
it's pretty good its order of D in terms
of time in practice it is better right
because in practice if I find a solution
I can just be done don't worry about the
rest of the tree but
in general if you want to talk about it
in theory then the worst case scenario
is just trying out all of the trees so
you write it as force case scenario it's
order of B to the D so so nothing has
really changed in terms of in terms of
exponential blow-up doll that tree
assumes that you applied the subproblems
to not overlap all right because you're
kind of branching of a kind of different
states but in fact a sub-problem could
overlap so somebody to trim problem you
can get to a same place with different
history but the rest are the same
yeah so you can it's so the question is
yeah do subproblems overlap here or they
don't so you could actually have it in a
setting where two subproblems do overlap
but you could actually add this this
extra like constraint that says if I
visited the state and don't add it to
the tree so so you have that option or
you have the option of like going down
the tree with some like particular
deaths and not trying out everything in
the setting that we have here yeah like
you're basically trying out all possible
like I'm talking about the most like
general form you're going over all the
states and all possible actions that
would come alright so that was CFS okay
so the idea of the FS again as you're
doing backtracking search and then
you're just stopping when you find a
solution because because cost is zero
here so in terms of space order of D in
terms of time it's still order of
utility alright so that was the FS we
have another algorithm called
breadth-first search BFS and this is
useful when cost is some constant but it
doesn't need to be zero it's just so
some some positive constant so what that
means is all these edges have the same
cost and that cost is just C the same
cost so the idea of breadth first search
is we can we can go layer by layer like
like we're not going to try out the
depth instead what we can do is we can
go layer by layer try out this layer and
see if you find a solution here remember
the tree doesn't need to go all the way
down here the tree could end here or
look at any of these and any of these
notes right like I can have like a tree
that looks you do like this
I have a solution here this tree doesn't
need to be this nicely formed like I can
have a tree that looks like this okay so
if I have a tree that looks like this
with breadth-first search I'm gonna try
out this layer see if this guy is a
solution if it's not I'm gonna try this
guy this is the solution if not I'm
gonna try here here and then when I find
a solution when I get here I'm done
right that's like if I find a solution
here I know it took to see to get here
like two of these see values and if
there is any other solution anywhere
else and this subtree or in this subtree
those solutions are going to be worse
than this because they're gonna just
like take like they are going to have a
higher cost so because the cost is
constant throughout so then it's it's
useful if your solutions are somewhere
like high up in this tree and then you
can find it so in terms of time I get
some improvements here because I can
call this steps it's shorter depth D
small D I'm gonna call it a shorter
depth small D and in terms of time it's
still exponential but it's order of B to
the small D and this is actually a huge
improvement because if you think about
it the trees exponentially become larger
so these like lower levels are a lot of
things that you need to you need to
explore if you have like branching
factor of 10 the next layer has a
hundred things in it right so so going
down these layers is actually pretty bad
so so the fact that with breadth-first
search i can improve the timing and then
limit it to a particular depth that's
pretty good still exponential but pretty
good if you have no negative cost so
that way you can also assume this
yeah you can assume that this is best
solution yeah exactly so you're assuming
that there are no negative costs so at
this point I know this the best solution
undone like I call it and I don't know I
guess for anything else
the problem with breadth-first search is
there's a question there sorry
so same yeah we are assuming all the
costs are same because maybe like all
the costs are one if I don't assume that
but all of these costs are 100 and then
like there might be like like some water
like yeah you need to explore the rest
if they're not the same basically
alright so so the problem with BFS is in
terms of memory we are losing in terms
of memory you need to actually keep
track of the history of all these other
like all the notes that you have
explored so far so in terms of memory
this is going to be order of B to the D
kind of similar to the time and then the
reason is I have explored this guy and
then after exploring this guy I need to
still have like a history of where it's
going to go because next time around
when I try out the Slayer I need to know
everything about this parent and I'd
like when I even explore here and this
is not a solution
I need to store everything about this
because maybe I don't find a solution in
this in this level and I need to come
down and then I come down I need to know
everything about these notes so I need
to actually store pretty much like
everything about the tree until I find
my solution and then that's where you
lose like in Brett's first search in
terms of space it's not going to be that
great so in terms of space it's now
order P to the D it's a lot worse than
what we have had in terms of time it is
better it's still exponential it's
better okay all right okay so now let's
talk about one more algorithm and then
after that we we jump to dynamic
programming where is a question back
here yeah so it is exponential I agree
so D can be the same as Big D but in
practice if small D is not the same as
Big D you're winning a lot because
because yeah these lower layers are so
bad that that people actually like to
call the call the fact that
or don't be to the small D EFS be big
worst case in there for the time and
awkward yet so Deena fest needs to go
all the way down to these lower lower
levels what vnfs can stop at every level
because it's doing a level by level yeah
so the reason is yeah so like if you're
saying okay so in DFS we were also
saving some time right like why aren't
you like calling that out and then the
reason is with DFS you still need to get
to these like more layers and that is
the like that is the place that you're
losing on time so so the fact that
you're still like losing on time and
sure like you haven't explored these
other ones but you have already got to
these lower trees like so far that's
pretty bad so that is why or they're
free to the D universe alright so this
last Tyler thing I want to talk about
this is an idea that tries it's a cool
idea it actually tries to combine the
benefits of VFS and DFS and then this is
called DFS iterative deepening so what
this algorithm does is it basically goes
level by level same SPFs because then
that way if you find a solution you're
done everything is great right
but with what it does is for every level
it runs a full DFS and it feels it take
it's gonna take a long time but it's
actually good because again if you find
your solution like early on it doesn't
matter that you have ran like a million
DSS's
so far so um so it's kind of like an
analogy of it is imagine that you have a
dog and that dog is DFS and it's on a
leash and you have like a short leash
and when it is on that leash it's going
to do a DFS and try out and search all
the space and it doesn't find it
anything so it comes back and then
you're going to extend the leash a
little bit and it's gonna do everything
and like to search everything and do a
DFS comes back doesn't find anything you
extend the leash again so so that's the
idea like extending the leeches this
idea of extending your your levels okay
so so how does how does DFS iterative
deepening in yes
bottom of the tree it's even worse than
both of mine
yes exactly yes that's okay that's a
good point so the point is the point out
that mentioned this if your solution is
like here you're screwed it's worse than
the FS or BFS right you're doing all
these DFS's through like a bigger like
higher level BFS and your and and it's
it's a terrible situation but again in
practice like we were hoping the
solutions are not gonna end up like down
the street but yeah if the solutions are
down the tree then you're not like
reading anything wait about using the SS
like problems do you think the FS area
name would be useful in general if you
okay so the question is yeah so in what
problems do we think the FSA deepening
is useful in general if like there are
problems that I think BFS is going to be
useful usually BFS iterative deepening
is useful the reason I would think that
is like there is some structure about
the problem that I would think I would
find my solution earlier so if I if I
have some reasons some some reasons
about the problem about the structure of
the problem and I think solutions are
low depth I should use some of these
algorithms and a DFS video rate of
deepening in terms of space it helps to
so might as well use that all right so
so in terms of space it's going to be
order of small Deena so in terms of
space or their small D and then in terms
of time it gets the same benefits of it
gets the same benefits of BFS so so
that's that's nice and then again like
because it's has this BFS out of the
loop it has the same sort of constraint
on it cost it's gotta be a constant
constraint guys pause alright so that is
our table and again in looking at this
table in terms of time you're just not
doing well right like we have this
exponential time algorithms here and we
could avoid the exponential space
reducing something like the FS iterative
deepening but still this time thing is
it's just not that great okay and what
we want to do in a now is you want to
talk about search algorithms that bring
down this exponential time to polynomial
time
somehow and then there is no magic we'll
talk about how and dynamic programming
is the first so so the way iterative
deepening works is it sets the local say
level is 1 so if level is 1 I'm gonna do
a full DFS okay because I'm doing a full
DFS interpretive space it's the same as
DFS in terms of space I just it's just
the same as the length where we find a
solution let's see the length where I
find a solution is small D so now I say
level is too many the level is - I'm
gonna do a full DFS yeah so when I do a
full DFS then in terms of space I need
to I need to just remember my parents so
that's why it's border of T in terms of
space and in terms of time its its order
of B to the D because if I find my
solution here I'm done I don't need to
like explore anything else and and that
is exponential about the exponential in
this smaller depth as opposed to longer
that's similar to similar to BFS I sorry
I still don't understand why let's say
like that's it okay so that's a very
good question so yeah I think I know it
so you're asking small D small D was the
same as Big D if I had my solutions down
here oh why am I like differentiating
here between a small D and Big D right
is that what you're asking for away
quite large like smoothies log oh I see
what you're saying so you're saying okay
like when I'm doing when I'm performing
DFS iterative deepening then I'm doing
DF DF SS so sure it's order of B to the
D for each of them but then I'm doing D
of them and if these really large I
should put that here sure I do agree
that is the right time but again like in
the case of this exponential this is so
bad that we are just dropping that like
don't even worry about that extra
t-that's come see but it is true you
need to have that extra D like in
general if you want to talk about it I
don't want to move on to dynamic
programming but last question just on
top of that presumably though you're
saving the work that you've done during
the prior iteration so you're not really
computing anything larger than the
capital d correct yeah that's right
the worst-case scenario is or to the
beat all right so let's move to dynamic
programming okay so so what does dynamic
programming do so maybe I can I'll still
use this cuz I might use this later okay
so you know erase my tram on here okay
so the idea of dynamic programming we
have already seen this in the first
lecture is I have a state s and I want
to end up in some end state but to do
that I can take an action that takes me
to s prime right I can I can end up in s
prime by cost of this a I can take an
action that not ends up in s prime and
then from there I can do a bunch of
things I don't know what but I'll end up
in some end State and what I'm
interested in actually computing is for
this state s is to find what is future
cost of and this part of it is future
cost that's fine and I don't know what
it is but I can just leave it as future
cost of s prime so if I want to find
what future cost of s is maybe I should
say feels a little bit to the right one
sense right cost of si for this edge
erase this what I'm interested in
finding is future cost of my stakes well
what is that equal to well that's going
to be equal to this cost of Si right
like at state s I'm gonna take action
okay so it's gonna be cost of Si plus
future cost of s Prime again I don't
know what that is but that's future
Dorset's problem so this is future cost
of s Prime
and then you might ask well what is a
where does a come from how do I know
what a is I don't know
I'm gonna pick an a that minimizes this
some around it okay so future cost of s
is just going to be equal to minimum of
cost of Si plus future cost of s prime
over all possible actions and it's going
to be zero if you're in an end State
this is end of true okay so if I already
know I'm in an end State and there is no
future cost that's going to be equal to
0 otherwise
future cost is just going to be cost of
going from s to the next state and then
future cost so that is just how one
would go about formalizing this problem
as a dynamic problem and they're not
dynamic programming problem and then how
do I find what s Primus well I wrote
this successor and cost function my code
remember like we know how to find a
successor given that we are in state s
and we are taking action a so s prime is
just calling that successor function
over SN a alright so let's go back to
some route finding example so so this is
a slightly different route finding
example so let's say that you want to
find the minimum cost path from going a
city 1 to some city end in the future
moving forward we can always just move
forward and it costs CIJ to go from city
I to CDJ ok so this is this is my new
search problem so so this is kind of how
the tree would look like so if I want to
draw this research for this I can start
from city one I can end up in city 2 or
3 or 4 then if I'm a city two I can end
up in 3 or 4 upon 3 I can end up in or
right like this is how I can have a much
larger version of it if I'm talking
about going to city 7 then I have this
type of tree and by just like looking at
this tree you see all these sub tree is
just being repeated like like throughout
right if
just looking at five like future costs
of five it's gonna be the same thing
this is gonna be the same thing
throughout and if I use like something
liked research said we have talked about
then I have to like go and explore like
this whole tree and then it's gonna be
really time-consuming so so the key
insight here is future costs this value
of future cost only depends on state
okay so it only depends on where I am
right now and because of that maybe I
can just store that the first time that
I compute future cost of five and then
like in the future I just call that and
then and I don't like recompute the
future cost of life so so the
observation here is future costs only
depends on current city so so my state
in this case is current city and then
that state is enough for me to compute
future costs all right so so if you if
you think about what we have talked
about so far like we have thought about
like these these search problems where
the stage we think of it as the past
sequence of actions in the history of
actions you have taken and all that but
right now for this problem like see is
just current city that's enough okay so
and because of that you're getting all
these exponential savings in time and
and space because again I can compute
future cost of five there and collapse
that whole tree into this graph and just
go about solving my search problem in
this graph as opposed to that that whole
tree yeah so so that's that's where you
get the savings from dynamic programming
and I just want to emphasize that again
all let me actually do this so so the
key idea here is like what I was saying
there's no magic happening here the key
idea here is is how to figure out what
your state is it's actually important to
think about what your status in this
case we are we're assuming the state is
summary of all parts all past actions
that we have taken sufficient for us to
choose the optimal future okay so so
that's like a mouthful but basically
what that means is the only reason
dynamic programming works and for this
particular example we just saw is the
state the way we define it is enough for
us to plan for the future I might have a
different problem where the state like I
defined a state in a way that it's not
enough for me to define for future but
if
I want to use dynamic programming then I
got to be smart about choosing my state
because because that is the thing that
decides for the future so so for example
for this problem like I might visit city
1 then 3 then 4 and then 6 and and for
solving this particular search problem I
just need to know that I'm in City 6
that is enough but like maybe I have
some other problem that requires knowing
1 3 4 and 6 and then because of that
maybe I need to know the full tree ok so
so this is where the saving comes from
like figuring out what the state is and
and defining that right all right so so
we'll come back to this notion of state
again and think about the state a little
bit more carefully but maybe before that
maybe we can just implement dynamic
programming real quick all right so
let's go back to our tram problem I'm
back to the tram problem and let's
implement dynamic programming ok so how
do we do this you're basically just
writing that like math over there into
code that that's all we're doing so so
we're going to define this future cost
if you're in an end state we're in
return 0 if you're not in an end state
we're just going to add up cost plus
future cost of s Prime how do we get S
Prime well you're going to call this
success a success and cost function so
we can get action new state and the
costs and then you're going to take the
minimum of them over over all possible
actions so minimum of cost plus future
cost of new states that is literally
what you have on your board
right
and we are returning a result so that is
Futurecast
what's your dynamic programming did it
should it should return future cost over
initial state right starts
you
and you returned the history if you want
in this case I'm not returning to
history okay so how do I get savings
well I got to put a cache right that's
the only way I'm gonna get savings so
that is where I put the cash and and if
I if the state is already in the cache
I'll just call my cache otherwise
question go supposed to go how are we
getting future costs how are we getting
so future caustics and States but what
actually this would like we have to have
like a function implemented if I
calculate your costs or is that like so
the future cost is going to be yes oh so
we have this function right future costs
overstate but you're gonna call future
costs so future cost over state is going
to be equal to cost of state and actions
in this function I'm saying all possible
actions try that out plus future cost of
s Prime and s Prime comes from the
successor and then cost function and a
successor and cost much
all right so an and yeah and so so we do
the caching the proper caching type of
way of doing this too and now we have
dynamic programming so we can basically
call this over our trying problem so I'm
gonna I'm gonna move forward
okay so let's do print solution dynamic
programming over our problem you can
again play around with this the only
baby I'm taking this is if it gives me
the same solution has backtracking
search because I knew how that works
right so let's just call it on ten and
yeah it gave me the same the same answer
so I can pull your own with this okay
all right so let's go back
okay so one assumption that we have here
to just point out is we're assuming that
this graph is going to be a cyclic so so
that's that's an assumption that we need
to make when we are solving this dynamic
programming problem and the reason is
well we need to compute this future cost
right for me to compute future cost of s
the SS prime I need to like have thought
about sorry for me to compute future
cost of s I need to have thought about
future cost of s prime so there is kind
of this natural ordering that exists
between my states so if I think about an
example over there are cycles then then
I don't have that ordering right if I
want to compute it let's say I want to
go from A to D here and C so if I want
to compute future cost of B I don't
really know if I should have computed
future cost of a before or C before or
what order should I have gone to compute
like future possibly so so you actually
need to have some way of ordering your
states in order to compute these future
costs and apply the dynamic programming
so that's why like we can't really have
cycles like let me let me think about
this algorithm but we are going to talk
about a uniform cost search which
actually allows us to have cycles like
in a few slides so the wrong time all
this is actually polynomial time into
order of states so order of N
yeah well remember and it's a number of
states all right so all right so let's
talk about the idea of States a little
bit more because I think this is this is
actually interesting right so so let's
just reiterate what is a state state is
a summary of all past actions sufficient
to choose future actions optimally okay
so so everyone happy but what status so
now what we want to do is we want to
figure out how we should define our
state space because again this is an
important problem right like how we were
defining state space is the thing that
gets the dynamic program you're working
so so we got it we got to think about
how to do that so so let's go back to
this example and let's just change that
a little bit so so this is the same
example of I'm going from city one to
see the end I can only move forward and
it costs CIJ to go from any city I to
say DJ and I'm gonna add a constraint
and the constraint is I can't visit
three odd cities in a row so what that
means is maybe I'm in state 1 and then I
went to state 3 or cd1 I went to city 3
and then after that can I go to City
Simon well no based on this constraint
that I've added I can't do that right so
I wanted to find a state space that
allows me to keep track of these things
so I can solve this new search problem
with this new constraint so so how
should i how should i do so in the
previous problem when we didn't have the
constraint our state was just the
current city like previously you just
cared about the current city and the
reason we cared about the current city
is like like we were solving the search
problem like they end up in a city you
need to know how I'm going where I
should go from 3 so I should I should
have my current city in general right so
so for the previous problem without the
constraint current city was enough but
now current city is not enough right I
actually need to know like something
about my path ok yeah that's actually a
very good point so one suggestion is
have a count of how many odd States
another maybe like and different maybe
the first thing I would come to our mind
is something
simpler so maybe we say well the state
is similar to its like the state like
when we say well the state is previous
city and current city
okay so this is one possible option for
for my state right cuz cuz if I have
this if I have this guy as my state and
then that is enough right like if I my
current city is three I know my previous
city was one I know I shouldn't go to
seven like that's enough for me to make
like future decisions yeah but there is
a problem with this well what is the
problem so I have n cities right so so
current city can take any possible
action and n possible states previous
city can also take and possible options
has impossible options so if I think
about the size of my state space it is n
squirt if I decide to choose this state
but if I decide to choose this state I'm
going to have n squirt
States and remember we are doing this
dynamic programming thing like we need
to actually like write down like like
how to get from all those states that's
gonna be big but there is an improvement
to this and that's the improvement that
you suggested which is I don't actually
need to have this whole giant previous
city which has n options I can just have
a counter to just know whether the
previous city was odd or not like that's
enough right like fight I don't care if
it was one or three or whatever right
like I just care to know if previous
city was odd or not so so another option
for alright it's here another option for
my state is to know if previous was odd
or not okay and I need to know my
current city again right currency do we
need that because like we need to know
how to get from there and then this
brings down my state space like how does
it bring down my state space because
well what's the size of my state space
this guy can take and possible states if
my previous city was odd that's too like
so I just brought down my state space
from something that was N squared 2 to N
and that's a good improvement so in
general learning you're picking these
state spaces you should pick them mini
more like sufficient thing for you to
make decisions so it's got to be a
summary of all the previous action
previous things that you need to make
future decisions but pick the minimal
one because you're stirring these things
and it actually matters to pick the
smallest one so so here is an example of
like exactly that so so my state is now
this tuple or whether the previous city
was odd or not and my current city so if
I start at city one well like I don't
have a previous city and I'm at City one
I could go to City three and I end up in
odd and three I could try to go to City
seven well that's not possible because
now I have good three state and end and
up here and there like the rest of the
tree you can have another example so so
the way I'm counting this is how so my
state is a tuple of two things right if
the previous city is odd or even I have
two options here it's either odd or even
that's too and then my current city and
I have n possible options for my
currency they could be sitting one city
to city three so that's n so I have any
options here I have two options here
that's why I'm saying my whole state
space is two times okay all right okay
so let's try out this example let's not
put it in just talk to your neighbors
about this and then maybe you have ideas
just let me know in a minute so okay so
what is the difference here so you're
traveling from city one to CDN and then
the constraint has changed now we want
to visit at least three odd cities so
that's what we want to do and then the
question is what is the minimal state
talk to your neighbors
all right any ideas
any ideas
what is a possible state like it don't
worry about the minimal event like for
now like what do I need to keep track of
number of this number of odd City okay
so is that it
do I need to just know number of odd
cities so number of what I meant is I
also need to have chrome City right so
okay so one possible option for this new
example I'm gonna write that here it is
I wonder is it at least three odd cities
I also need my to know my current city
for any of these types of like not any
of these types of problems look for
these particular problems that I've
defined here I need to know where I am
so I need to know what my current city
is so so that is like that is given what
I need to talk okay so I want to see at
least three odd cities so one possible
option is to just have a counter I keep
counting number of odd cities so this
could be one potential yes or maybe one
three one so okay so the question is do
the cities need to be different the way
they are defining the problem is we're
moving forward if I'm in one like I can
just move forward I can't like say add
one or I can't like go back so so we're
always moving forward but when we talk
about the state space we're talking
about the more general setting like some
of some of that 2n might not even be
possible
that's alright so so this is one option
but I can actually do better than this
and then you're done right so a
suggestion there is we can you didn't
have like you can use at least three odd
cities then you need at least two art
reduced and at least one art city and
then you're done and one way of
formalizing that that's exactly right
like I don't care if I have four art
cities now or five art cities like as
long as I have like a buff three that's
that's good enough right one odd city to
our cities three art city and
that is just three Foss like like that's
enough for me okay so if I had this then
the state space here is going to be an
options here and number of odd cities
it's around and over two so it's going
to be N squared over two
but if I use this this new suggestion
where I don't keep track of four or five
six seven I just keep track of one two
and three plus then my state space ends
up becoming three times N and I can
formally write that as s is equal to
minimum of number of odd cities and
three and then current cities needs the
current city and with this state space
then size is equal to three so I just
pick up brought down and squared to n
and that's a nice yes not also need an
option for zero visibility we're
starting from city one so you're already
counting that in but yeah like if you
have zero answer
all right so haha okay so that was that
this is how it look like like you can
think of your state space like this
again has a two pole of I visited one
two three and and then the cities I have
another example here you can think about
this later and yeah like work it at home
but basically the question is again
you're going from city 1 to n and you
want to visit more odd cities than even
cities what would be the minimum states
but you can talk about it offline so the
summary so far is is that state is going
to be a summary of past actions
sufficient to choose future actions
optimally and then dynamic programming
it's not doing any magic right it's
using this notion of state to bring down
this exponential time algorithm to a
polynomial time algorithm and then the
trick of using memorization and with the
trick of choosing the right state okay
and we've talked about dynamic
programming and how it doesn't work for
cyclic graphs and now we want to spend a
little bit of time talking about uniform
cost search
and how that can help with the cycles so
if you guys have seen Dijkstra's
algorithm this is very similar to
de-stress like yeah so it's basically
like stars but alright so let's let's
actually talk about this so so the
observation here is that when we when we
think about the cost of getting from
start state to some s prime well that is
going to be equal to cost of going from
s to s prime and then some past costs of
us and then been dynamic programming
like we make sure that we have this
ordering and these things are computed
in order so we're not worried about like
visiting the states like multiple times
but within in uniform path search we
might visit the state multiple times and
if you have cycles we don't know what
order to go but the order we can go is
we can actually compute a past cause the
suggested path cost and and basically go
over the states based on increasing past
costs okay so let me actually yeah so so
uniform cost search what it does is it
numerous states in an order of
increasing past costs so and then in
this case we need to actually make an
assumption here we need to assume that
the the cost is going to be non-negative
so so I'm making this assumption for
uniform cost search so here is an
example of uniform cost search running
oh we don't have internet I just yeah
there is a video of uniform cost search
running in action and if I have time now
connect to internet and get it working
but so so let's talk about the
high-level idea of uniform cost search
so in uniform cost search we have three
sets that we need to keep track one is
explored set which is the states that we
have found the optimal path you sort of
stay say we're sure like how to get to
you have computed the best as possible
to get there we are like done with them
yeah then we have another set called a
frontier where this frontier are the
states that we have seen you've computed
like a cost of getting there like you
know somehow how to get there and what
would be the cost but you're just not
sure about it like you're not sure if
that was the best way of getting there
okay so
so the frontier you can think of it as a
known unknown I know they exist but like
I actually I'm not sure what's the
optimal way of getting there and then
finally we have this unexplored part of
states and these unexplored part of
state I haven't even seen them yet I I
don't even know how to get there and you
can think of it as more of an unknown
unknown so so that's like how you would
think about these three
so let's actually work out an example
for uniform cost search I'm actually
going to do this one so so I'm just
gonna show how uniform cost search runs
on this example so I said we are going
to keep track of three sets unexplored
frontier and then explore it okay all
right so everything ends up an
unexplored at the beginning
a B C and D and what I want to do is I
want to go from A to D right that's what
I want to do okay so I want to find a
minimum pass cloth minimum cost path to
get from A to D given that I have this
graph so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
take my initial State that's a I am
going to put a on my frontier and it
costs zero to get to a because I'm just
starting at a okay so that's on my
frontier then the next step what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna pop off the thing
with the lowest cost from my frontier
there's one thing on my frontier I'm
just gonna pop off that one thing off my
frontier I'm gonna put that to export
the cost of getting to a is zero and
then what I'm going to do is after
popping it up from my frontier is I'm
gonna see how I can get from a to any
other state so from a I can get to B
that's one option
and with the cost of one so from a I can
go to be the cost of one where else can
I go
I can go to see speed acosta 100 okay so
what I just did is I move be from
unexplored to frontier and then I I know
how I to get there from a and I move to
say to a frontier and I know how to get
there so now it's the next round I'm
looking at my frontier
he's not on my frontier anymore it's an
export and I'm gonna pop up the thing
with the best cost of my frontier
well what is that that's B so I'm going
to move B to my export the way the best
way to get to B I already know that
right that's from A to B everything is
good okay so now that have popped off B
from my frontier I'm gonna look at me
and see what state I can get to from
from P I can go to a but a is already in
export like I already know the best way
to get to a so so there is no reason to
do that from B I can get to see and if I
want to get to C then I can actually get
to see with the cost of 1 plus whatever
cost of B is already 1 so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna erase this because
there's a better way of getting there
and that's from me okay and then from me
I can get to D so I'm gonna move D from
an export to front here I can get to it
from B and then how do I get to it from
me there's a cost of 1 0 1 alright
because 100 plus cost of getting to
alright so I'm done exploring everything
I can do from be going back to my
frontier again so these two are not on
my frontier I just have C and D on my
frontier
I'm gonna pop off the thing with the
best cost that is C I'm gonna move that
to export with the cost of tooth and the
way to eat the best way to get that is
from B okay so we're done with C and
then we're gonna see where we can go
from C from C I can go to a well that's
done that's already on export and export
said I'm not going to touch that similar
thing with P already in export don't
need to worry about that from C I can
get to D right and if I want to get to D
from
CEO what would be the cost of that it
would be two plus one so I can update
this and have three and I can update the
way to get to D from here and then we're
done we go to frontier the only thing
that's left on the frontier is D I'm
gonna just pop that off and then I'm
gonna add that to exports and that is
three and that's what I have in my
exports so the way to get from A to D is
is by taking this route and it costs one
so a b c ND okay is that is that clear
alright okay so there are two slides
left and they're probably gonna kick us
out soon so I'll do this next time so so
yeah the to two slides left is one is
going to just go over there the
pseudocode so take a look at that the
code is online and there's a small
theorem that says this is actually doing
the right thing I'll talk about that
next time